and nowhere is this more apparent than
in the very famous mosque Cathedral of
Cordoba a place where Islam and
Christianity meet and where we can
experience the course of history quite
literally as we walk its incredibly
beautiful Halls the Rahman established
al-andalus as a center for the Umayyads
with the city of Cordoba at its very
center a position that it would hold for
many centuries thereafter
it was also Abdul Rahman the first that
began the construction of the great
mosque in the city around the year 756.
Andalucia is a place with so much
history and interesting things to
discover
umayyad Empire and eventually caliphate
grew into a very significant political
and cultural force over the coming
centuries and Cordoba was at the very
center of all of this